oh my god it's happened the music video
games are back Justin they're back
scoffs they're back I heard finally rock
band 4 is that Guitar Hero live is out
in like two weeks time something like
that yeah people were so excited when
these were announced well now people are
kind of just oh yeah that's cool
it's really strange that like we waited
for so long for anyone to make a move on
this and then they boat release within
two weeks of each other
they had to yeah like pretty creates a
very pre-christmas thing do you think
like this type of game you you have to
get that you have to get it on shelves
now get people aware of it and like
those things are gonna take up a lot of
shelf space that was one of the things
that killed it in the first place is
that you have this very expensive thing
takes up a lot of shelf space and that
means other things can't be on store
shelves and a lot of retailers didn't
like doing that yeah rock band 4 out
today yes guitar girl I've had on
October 20th
so both these games have seemingly done
a good job of like ensuring that you can
use old instruments there is access to
back catalogue a lot of it as well you
can go broke immediately rock band is
one that's very compatible with the
previous catalogue with previous
instruments Guitar Hero is a very
different experience like so I wouldn't
say both games rock band is definitely
trying to be a similar game to what it
was historically guitar hero is going in
a completely different direction but we
can discuss that cool all right let's
talk with you Scott about the review
first of all 7/10 that one games.com and
what are your main takeaways from rock
band for the the biggest takeaway is
that it is it's still rock band which is
both good and bad I mean it was it was
actually pretty difficult for me because
I I'm a huge you know rock band fan I
love the previous games I played a you
know an embarrassing amount of rock band
2 both by myself and with other people
and so playing this was like oh yeah
it's it's a lot like rock band 2 again
which is like well that's an experience
that I loved and that I actually scored
a 10 at a different outlet you have to
work for it and so they don't I'm in
place
yeah and that was that was like you know
barackman to about six maybe even seven
years ago at this point so it was kind
of like well how do i how do i score an
experience that is something that I
still love but has now you know hasn't
changed much
that in the intervening period and I say
rock band to not rock band 3 because
rock band 3 you know introduce the the
pro controller and tried to be more of a
almost a teaching tool and this really
steps back from that and goes back to
the party game experience of the first
and second game so really I focused more
on 2 than 3 for that reason and and what
I kind of landed on is you know it is a
great experience but without more sort
of new ideas and without more content
truthfully it was difficult for me to
give it anything higher than a 7 which
I'd like to point out is still a good
score on the game spot scale 7 is good
and and and it is I mean rock band is an
incredibly thrilling experience it's
something you can share with people I
was all very excited to get people to
come play with me when I was reviewing
it had a great time I just wish that
there had been you know more new ideas
more new content more stuff to really
sink your teeth into ok that's nuts dive
into that then first of all what's the
sort of main progression is it a career
mode are you on the road like you are in
previous rock band games yeah so the
basic setup for the campaign is you are
you know young bands starting out
growing your career and gradually paying
bigger bigger shows it's essentially the
same premise we've seen throughout every
music game so yeah a phenomenon started
the sort of novel approach this time is
you can choose between yeah like there's
a good example on screen you can choose
a different path depending on you know
what you want to do you can take you
know you know you can buy a van and tour
the country in a van or you can get a
manager and you'll get you know more
money if you pick a manager but get more
fans if you choose a van right it's all
these binary decisions and on these
menus they look it's just menus yeah I
mean that's what kind of ruined it for
me I mean it's an interesting idea I
like the idea that you're making choices
but one the choices basically boiled
down to which costume items you unlock
that's all it really means if you're
going to get items either way your
choices dictates which ones you get and
second the fact that the story is
related entirely through menu text it's
just kind of disappointing me in my
review I refer back to loading screens
from rock band 2 and the glory screens
are normally so boring right but in rock
band 2 it would take your custom created
characters and it would show them and
sort of different band related settings
like in a practice space or a train with
their instruments on the subway I
remember just kind of sense that your
band was a real thing and it was so
great it was so subtle and I'm so
relatable without any
log or any real characters besides your
own so it doesn't have any of that so
this doesn't yeah it just it just has
menu text which to me is just not as
relatable it's not as immersive and so
the whole campaign structure was just
kind of lost on me it just I didn't
really get much out of it and it doesn't
ruin the gameplay you can still trip it
and have fun but to be fair nobody plays
rock band for the story and yeah like
like I was just saying it doesn't ruin
the gameplay for going in just to rock
out with your friends this doesn't
affect that it's just that it didn't add
anything when it really could have said
yeah it feels like a missed opportunity
I was passed since the previous game
yeah let's talk about what is props the
most difficult thing to do as a reviewer
when it comes to these games is these
games oftentimes live and die on how
much you enjoy the tracklist and that's
like such an incredibly subjective thing
like I went in and played and it was
like two or three track track said that
I really really wanted and I go back and
like I've owned I think like maybe
almost all of the rock band Guitar Hero
games at one stage and the ones that I
really really loved are the ones that
had like ten songs that I've always
wanted to play or like I could get the
DLC for it so talk about that for a
little while like what is the tracklist
like in rock band 4 did you have any
experience like pulling in tracks that
you'd already bought in previous rock
band games what was that all like yeah
well we've been testing all the DLC
stuff today actually I'm hoping to put
up a an FAQ of sorts oh cool
within the next you know like probably
sometime later today that covers a lot
of those topics but to speak to the
tracklist it was a little disappointing
I mean you know you were saying that you
would always look for those tracks that
she's really excited you couldn't
believe that this was in the game you
couldn't wait to play it I feel like for
a lot of people this list didn't have
too many of those songs it had a lot of
sort of like lesser-known songs from big
artists or bands that nobody had ever
really heard of her about and so I mean
reading comments ahead of time in any
preview of the game the comments are
really like all the track was stuck just
Kim's gonna be awful how are they almost
painted themselves into a corner with I
think it's like the previous games I've
had some of their like best yeah they've
used all the good Drax oh let me in like
dude there's so much good music from all
time that like there's there's never not
gonna be good tracks but you're right
that it when it comes to licensing it
can be difficult you've run out of stuff
that you can reasonably acquire after a
while and yeah they're like
2100 DLC tracks from what they what they
seem to be pulling for is you've played
these games
or and now you're gonna be able to
transfer those over to this current game
right yeah which I haven't you know
again we're experimenting with that but
so far I haven't heard any real negative
feedback from anybody it seems to be
working at okay and I appreciate
harmonicas commitment to making that
possible but in defensively on disc
songs because again so many people were
just hating on it outright I think there
were actually a lot of sort of hidden
gems within there that I found songs
that I didn't expect to love that I
either grew to love the song itself or
at the very least I enjoyed playing it
sometimes songs that you don't listen
necessarily listening to have an
interesting hook that can translate
really well to gameplay so I found stuff
to love even within a list that at first
glance doesn't look super straight I
have a Spotify playlist of a couple of
songs that I played while just going in
there and having a job at lunchtime one
day just like there's a couple of ones
that I picked up them yeah you might be
surprised by the stuff that stands out
and yeah I guess it's the last sort of
question about it this is another sort
of difficult aspect of reviewing a game
like this is the costs required to buy a
game like this so give us a sort of a
breakdown of like new instruments are
there packs
did you use old instruments that the new
ones work better like how much's are
worse like where do you feel the value
prospect really is in rockland that's
that's another thing we're working on
testing and something that Harmonix and
Mad Catz are both really committed to
that they really wanted to make sure
that as many instruments as possible
we're compatible
in fact in within the review if you go
to the site there's a link to a Mad Catz
chart that illustrates basically all of
the instruments that should work with
rock band 4 including like Guitar Hero
and third party yeah and they do like
that most of them seem to be pretty like
compatible it's actually it's amazing
how many of them it's a substantial
majority I think it's the way I phrased
it in the review and and yeah it does
need to be the bulk of the instruments
actually do work and and there are new
instruments if you want to go out and if
you you know if you haven't hung on your
stuff you can't go by the band in a box
and I know a lot of people Balch at the
price tag and it you know it does seem
pretty pricey but you know and I kind of
grappled with that when when writing the
review cos like man you know do you
treat this as a normal $60 game and and
actually had a really interesting
conversation with with Peter Brown or
reviews editor about this and basically
what it came down to is it's not really
up to reviewers to decide the value of a
dollar
I mean 250 bucks to one person is not
250 bucks to another person really you
know depends on the individual and their
income and what they consider disposable
or in that $250 isn't actually it's
actually 60 because they own all the
answer
exactly I don't want to play drums or or
they have like it's on sale and yeah oh
yeah I heard from now when all this
stuff is half-price anyway yes for me
that didn't really factor into the
review although it is an important
consideration that again you know we'll
be covered in the frequently asked
questions that are putting together how
all that stuff works and what's back
what you paddle and all that stuff so
that's sort of how I approach that
portion of the review cool
seven out of ten on GameSpot con Justin
you looking forward to playing it at all
I am I'm a little surprised at some of
the things that were taken away like you
mentioned this a little bit in the
review and like it is a great experience
when you're just playing with friends
but it feels like this game is meant to
be played with friends this is no longer
a single-player experience both in terms
of how the the progression the the story
that you're going through like yeah sure
it's not that big but it doesn't really
give you that that compelling hook that
you might have had in previous games and
the first thing that I did was like oh
I'm gonna play the game by myself I want
to get a little bit better it's been a
while so I'm a little bit rusty I pick
up the guitar I'm like I didn't quite
get that under my fingers let me
practice that oh there is no practice
mode like yeah so you you go you're
gonna just get good by playing the game
just kind of more like the original rock
bands the original Guitar Hero's so it's
not horrible but it's when you've gotten
used to those little touches the the
small things that make it fun to play
and that make you a better player it
feels like those are missing and it's a
strange that those were taken out its
add one thing to that Harmonix has
stated that they're working on adding
content and we should expect you know a
major patch with that's potentially free
that includes new gameplay and maybe
even things like a practice mode by like
December okay but I didn't really
consider that in the review because
that's more like what rock band will
eventually maybe become not the part of
it you can actually go out and buy today
so I didn't really consider that but
it's you know just something that's good
to know if you are a fan or if you are
considering buying the game in the
future you may get more content cool all
right Scott Butterick thank you so much
Justin hey old
thank you very much god god dammit yeah
why
really I'm that he did it so I didn't
have to do any you guys live on like a
like a lower grand apartment I do you do
yes is you just moved into a site I've
been living at a box its current good
call
cuz that means you can play the drums I
just moved into a place it's like
underneath this comedian dude who he's
probably already angry that like my
stuff my girl has two cats have fights
in like four o'clock in the morning and
make all this noise you're giving a
material great there you go yeah yeah
maybe I should just start playing drums
the whole set about his terrible
neighbor work said thanks for coming on
talking us all about rock band really
appreciate it thank you guys for
watching let us know what you think rock
bands have you kept any of your
instruments from Guitar Hero rockbound
you're gonna wait and see what Guitar
Hero live is all about let us know in
the comments below